ça ira ça ira le grand palais va être
pendant trois mois le centre de la danse
française
un thème dansant révolution et de
nombreux et prestigieux spectacle de mai
à juillet début des festivités le 2 mai
prochain avec maurice béjart
parmi les quelques privilégiés qui ont
pu avoir un avant-goût de cette
production un fan de choc
mireille mathieu merveilleux par ce
cadre est alors quand maurice va évoluer
sur cette manne guide celle ci
ils sont tous venus admirer la merveille
une structure de spectacles en plein
coeur de paris en chasser dans les
tenailles à volutes de fonte d'un palais
centenaire 36 mètres d'ouverture sur 650
mètres carrés d'espacé pour l'évolution
de la danse sous le feu de 400
projecteurs mais ce qui est beau c'est
le ciel c'est qu'on est vraiment ce
matin il y avait du soleil c'est
extraordinaire maintenant un peu brumeux
mais ça change comme une comme le ciel
des grands plein air et puis voyez ce
qui est fantastique c'est cup
on a joué le jeu du clown r on n'a pas
apporté de décor on n'a pas apporté
d'éléments scéniques
il ya l'espace et l'espace avec toutes
les structures avec les escaliers les
marches les colonnes on joue dans tout
l'espace on n'a pas cherché à imposer
une scénographie on a joué dans le grand
palais pour le grand palais
45 mètres de haut pour atteindre les
sommets d'une saison où se croiseront
révolution sur pointes et flamenco
bicentenaire chaque créateur allant de
son imaginaire pour raconter les
histoires et l'histoire la langue en
outre appuyé ensuite je dirais que c'est
pas uniquement un spectacle de danse
d'un grand spectacle de cirque de
théâtre il ya un acteur qui michel
dussarat à la bûche savary il y à il ya
des chevaux et des acrobates
il ya des enfants beaucoup de danseurs
bien sûr je crois que c'est un spectacle
comme je fais baudelaire dans le temps
où angie ce qui dans lequel se
retrouvent intègre total surtout un
théâtre projeté dans un petit espace
ainsi ce recréera chaque soir d'été sous
la verrière l'instant magique pour 4275
spectateurs pas un de moins
suspendu entre tubulures et rêve